what do you think of beeps gonna do now
but I think who could be yeah
well he does whatever the [ __ ] he wants
to do that's what I think I think that
guy's probably the best lightweight of
all time he's a monster
incredible he I think he's probably
gonna have some fights at 170 pounds
eventually if I'd imagine at 155 there's
you know there's good fights for him
Tony Ferguson it's a great fight for him
I've really interested in seeing that
I'm really interested in seeing him
going up I'm really interested to see
him fight at 170 pounds looking from the
fight well first of all tyron woodley
who's the champ
at 170 that would be an insane fight
George st. Pierre if you decided to come
back and make a big super fight that
would be an insane fight I think 170 has
a lot of opportunities for him but I
think 155 does too they just have to
figure out who's gonna fight him he's an
international superstar now you know
Kabhi especially the way he smashed
Conor Conor such a superstar already
that the way khabib won and did it so
dominant I think he's I think he's
through the roof now I think when people
when he comes back and people see the
pay-per-view numbers of his fights are
gonna realize how huge this guy is
because he's so interesting he's very
humble very very he's very polite very
well-spoken a very religious guy lives
with his family lives of his parents
lives of his parents his family I
believe yeah I hope I'm not speaking out
of school I believe that's true and
obviously it doesn't have to for money
he's rich as [ __ ] now yeah but he's just
a monster the best best grappler I've
ever seen inside 155-pound division he
just smashes people anything but John
Jones doe whatever in what way and his
skill is phenomenal incredible the best
ever at using distance he knows distance
better than anybody he's a master at
knowing when he can hit you and you can
hit yeah I miss watching them fight I
mean he's back you just won just won the
title again just fine Alexander
Gustafsson yeah yeah a couple weeks ago
yeah bacon pate oh it was Daniel Cormier
relinquished his title and it was like
it's weird right
a Cormier is the champ because Jon Jones
tested positive for something so they
stripped him and then Cormier became the
champ
it's uh you know I think they'll
probably fight again whether they fight
again and heavy weight or light heavy
really yeah I think Cormier and John
Johnson for me wants to once keep going
he says he wants to retire soon he's 40
you know yeah I feel looks good he looks
great
especially at heavyweight and
heavyweight he's he doesn't have to cut
weight he's got so much strength and -
so agile he's such an unbelievable
wrestler - I mean his wrestling skill
his skill level and understanding of
wrestling is so high so above mostly
anybody he find out find a gym John
Jones he dominates yeah yeah that's how
good John is John's dad good he's doctor
I mean it just sucks that he's had so
many controversies in his life but I'm
hoping he puts all that [ __ ] behind him
have you ever spoken with him about that
yeah never Bundys personal life anything
when we met before and talked well
you're a guy who's gone I mean when you
went through legal problems yourself you
you overcame you came out of it on the
other hand I think would think a guy
like him could benefit a lot from so
it's just so difficult and so
unfortunately they have to go do
something yeah you know do you think so
yes you know sometimes people they don't
survive situations like that cuz they're
so wild and they're having a good time
too much in the party and head of the
champ you have to have to come to an end
that's tough if you don't bring it to an
end bring come to his own end it might
not like that yeah so you think Ferg I
like him maybe getting in trouble was a
good thing if only if you learn from
experiences like that yeah you know I
thought I was just a wild guy I was
really a wild look at myself now and I
say to myself when I think those trips
in those psych wards and so what was
that all about what what's wrong with me
back then you know yeah really disturbed
back then but you're somebody who got to
the point where you got like it's really
fascinating because I know you know
you're a public figure so we you know
I've been able to watch you my whole
life you went through all that stuff and
then you got to this point where you're
a very self-reflective and you look at
you are able to comment on it I don't
think most I mean most people regardless
of whether they're famous or not just
still don't get to that point where
they're able to look
back and examine who they were and doing
wild [ __ ] and with ruthless honesty yeah
that's okay reflecting itself to
discover who you really are